I wish you could see mine
welcome to podcast ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
Squarespace ready to start your new
business make it stand out think it
dream it destiny is calling it says you
need a new website make it happen with
Squarespace the future is coming make it
brighter with Squarespace
keep dreaming but making a reality
brother with a website from Squarespace
this is what I'm gonna do today head to
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch when you're ready
write all your goals down and get this
business tip-top Magoo and turn your
cool ideas into a website go that
squarespace.com get yourself a free
trial and when you're ready to go use
offer code Church CH you are CH to save
10% off your first purchase of website
or domain this is your chance that
squarespace.com enter code Church the
podcast is also brought to you by as I
like to call the goods on it eyelid
supplements are always there for you you
know why I'm still here tick tock Magoo
2 planes
breathe them on people's [ __ ] neck
why because a shroom tech immune you
take two they take that time to take to
the more [ __ ] people I see the more I
take I'm up to about 10 shrimp eggs
immunes a day you don't see me [ __ ]
call for this Sneasel around I got kids
shroom tech immune shroom tech sport you
want to last longer this is our this is
how it's done and for that [ __ ]
protein that's needed the [ __ ] hemp
for its protein the cocoa will put a pep
in your step but don't take it from me
go to adam.com right now and press in
charge BAM and get 10% off your first
order if you go with alpha brain you
want to get your head together get a
little alpha brain listen to me you
don't like it you get a hundred percent
money-back guarantee and we don't want
the pot product back alright it's that
simple
go 200 calm slash Church boom will get
you 10% off 1
time for Squarespace and one more time
400 kick that [ __ ] mule Lee how
wonderful life is why you're in the
world are you [ __ ] kidding me
if you said that ta cat wants it or your
[ __ ] mailman you live to your ninety
understand me those are the kindest
words you can ever say to somebody and I
heard that song about a week ago and
they almost put the car in reverse on
the 405
just let it because I forgot what life
was about until I heard that song we all
forget on a daily how [ __ ] beautiful
life is and it takes the stupid [ __ ]
song to remind you that see you guys
look at out Johnny look at a fat [ __ ]
guy with glasses on will probably suck
the thousand [ __ ] that might be true
you know anyone's 800 ticket that might
be true but he said the blueprint in
this country for guys like me that were
[ __ ] immigrants and I came and this
is the music gear and you're like god
damn I'm in the right [ __ ] place
Elton John dropped this and everything
changed this was magnificent well anyway
enough about Elton John what's happening
at all though hi Joe - yeah well your
[ __ ] skull had old school Philly fan
threw a can at the [ __ ] doctor
batteries and we got the flaming Jew
over here find you flaming flaming it
the whole time that Elton John the
flaming cuz that K so finally came out
here at all
Oh from Houston I did think of Austin I
did think about you this morning cuz I
went to the bathroom and it just took it
I was like goddamn and he was right
about that
oh yes that's constipation that just
walks into you but I want to thank it's
worth it
Austin Texas I want to thank the cap
city comedy club for a phenomenal
weekend I mean I realized something this
weekend that that Club isn't even a club
to me no more it's family I went there
as an open mic Rijn got on this stage
outside on Wednesday nights then Joe
brought me in Tennessee then I featured
and now my headline man it's a [ __ ]
family type environment
Saturday night I want to thank all the
savages that came out my man from Dallas
Dave and I want to congratulate Bobby
sham
and crystal and their engagement they
had the [ __ ] lieutenants of the
church or what's happening now kooky
spooky showed up Ron White was there
Danny Brown was there I mean it was just
a great night
it was just a great weekend so thank you
for you guys for making me feel at home
only Texas acts that way you follow me
Texas is a great place to perform a
service they say it's awesome I've never
been only to El Paso but not to perform
here's the problem with Texas that the
whole state is alive and kickin like
yeah you could look at somebody and go
you know what things aren't going quite
that way you know I really want to get
good economy and you don't really and
you want to get the experience just get
in the car go to Texas do the clubs it's
Shelby you could stop at any bar in
Texas or how you doing man you got a
microphone here you mind if I go up
there do ten minutes and they'll let you
it's Texas you better be good yeah you
better be god they got the jukebox on
yeah yeah you can't do that [ __ ] maybe
one you can't turn the jukebox from one
side of Texas to the other it's a week
and a half
oh Jesus that's huge so we gonna have
but it's another week of you're the top
and go down you have a month of comedy
in Texas yeah nobody really understands
that you have a month of copy of now
repeating the same place he's like you
could go yeah Wow
but Ron White sent that on our podcast
he did the Comedy Store one and he told
us that like Texas made him a great
comic played in those little circuits
and then they move you up you know maybe
seeing Lois they have a one there and
they throw you around he said that's how
he came out that was one of those states
where if you really really want to learn
about comedy Texas or coach Texas will
let you take the ride mm-hmm you better
view Texas will let you take the ride
but you better back your [ __ ] guns
with Texas because that's how you lose
them like I noticed that have you talked
about Bush in Austin they would clap if
you mention Bush in Houston
so you have to learn different
parameters you know is he from Austin
and Houston he had a ranch in Houston so
okay be like if you do calmly in Conroe
yeah yeah those places they're a lot
different than doing them in Houston
yeah you know it's just a moment it's
just a very interesting moments I think
yeah you have wrong moments towards
Louisiana but it's just I I did
everything that if I went back in my
notebooks Jesus Christ
I remember doing Corpus Christi with
Freddie me and Mark Babbitt that's
amazing and having 16 people in the
audience and you know like nobody really
knew Freddie was you know like but I
would do all having been doing a barn in
Corpus Christi Corpus Christi I'm gonna
be doing a place that at the end of the
night Marilyn Kwame she goes did you get
your [ __ ] Joey it was like eight hundred
but I left before the guy gave up the
yum-yum tree ah someone goes I have it
here for you but go down he was looking
for you that went there and there was a
chunk of [ __ ] coke you know I was
there in Midland surprised you didn't
become the house opener there oh my god
I was there in Middleton when the guy
tried to rape Merrill and when he tried
to push the door and she called the cops
and I go Marilyn he didn't know you were
in there you know I cuz he wouldn't rape
you if he's know what you look like he
would direct you it was a hotel in a
hotel by the pool yeah the doors were
surrounding the pool and somebody tried
to break in the mouth oh Jesus and then
another time there was a club down there
that I went then twice at the DEA the
DEA swarmed the host was a combination
magician horrible comic always said that
he was married in two different states
and he was wanted for milega me whatever
another's polygamy yeah look at me when
you burn sister-wives yeah dog how was
it cokehead that's every single [ __ ]
ounce in my body
this guy made me look like a [ __ ] kid
he gave us all hate balls when we walked
in for the Friday night show and he said
watch this disappear and there was two
shows he had one two
tweeting the second show he came up to
me and asked me if I had anything left
he had done the whole [ __ ] oh my god
he would go on stage sweating [ __ ]
leaking out of his nose
it was El Paso you know I don't go to a
Paso anymore okay
I know Paso I cut my comedy teather easy
Hey
yeah easy he got me into that room
Freddie and what's the club there the
comic strip Freddie Freddie and Roger
Paul got me into that room and I ended
up doing up that room probably there was
a year I was probably there six times
just as what as the Oh Burke has a
feature bring it down a long time
sometimes three one time I stayed three
weeks as a feature there Wow
I was supposed to work in Corpus Christi
Roger Paul got me some gig he was last
year and I would calling him and calling
on like Jude Shep I had taken that all
the sudden I think the club closed or
something Roger books you see you don't
have to call him anymore
the club is booked they call him a week
ahead because I was just gonna call you
what happened they changed it the one a
woman they turn coming in to bingo night
so yeah you got all the good ones yeah
you know that all the shysters are out
there the advantages of the beginner
comics like if you could write a book as
a beginner comic of all the [ __ ]
thieves out there oh and it's funny that
there's a handful of them that are just
this like my friend Mikey Klein over I
won by one podcast he does the podcast
he's a dad and then he does like [ __ ]
design on the side for a couple comics
and I've hooked them up I mean like web
design like those pictures all those
pictures is my decline
okay Mikey does this picture from time
to time they'll call me to go this
content this comic contacted me not home
stay away cuz they're gonna be a lot
more drama with their work yes
especially the high-end comic they have
people doing shipping them for free all
the time when you ask them for money
their feelings
and then they stopped talking to you yes
because they think everything should be
for free
yeah and for the years I totally I love
comics but there's comics we don't make
money you know that's why comics post
[ __ ] like we'll do this for free over
Bob because they don't want to pay and
then it's just a [ __ ] weird dynamic
yeah I want to pay you so you're happy
and you're happy the car the person
happy you get what you pay for you yeah
you know these people start these comics
and podcasts and they'll tell a producer
listen we'll get you money after the
[ __ ] we had a sponsor you sitting
there a year there's no sponsors kid
yeah giving up five hours of his time
gotta give him something gotta get my
burger
mmm something mean I'm saying that stage
time the last cry tonight at Joe Joe's
[ __ ] Chinese joint but you got to take
care of the guys because there's none
it's like anything else in life one day
the guy's gonna get up and go why am I
even doing this yeah this benefited me
at all and Hollywood has a very weird
way of doing that to be oh yeah
not me $100 a day movies I shop at the
people working for free and they work
like meals and they were getting yelled
at you yell at me for free I will break
this over your [ __ ] arms but before
would you do it like back in the day you
want to do it not for free you got to
give me something there's always some
somebody's making enough money there
that you can't give me five hours an
hour I don't have to prove myself that
way inches you can either catch somebody
to come in five days a week for eight
weeks for free they gotta feed
themselves they got a family or they
over their mother's basement they gotta
justify that you know there's got to be
something I one of my passions in life
has always been masonry okay
I love masonry interesting fight you
know I am amazingly why put earphones on
nobody bothers you you design a warrior
self okay okay and they took that trade
away from this country because the
master [ __ ] brick guys were guineas
when they came over you know you ever
said episode of Sopranos when he takes a
Jay to the church
oh yeah you guys forget the brickwork by
the line all the brickwork love East
Coast Pittsburgh agreed all the way down
to Philadelphia so just doing it and
it's still no no they're not doing it
you know what some of them that [ __ ]
don't break the beginning oh I hear what
you're saying those gang walls from 1910
they don't go down hmm they dip those
guineas where they built the wall
delusive leaving did they know they're
prepared you're saying it's named the
Mexican walls you can just poke them I'm
not saying that what I'm saying is that
over the years for you to learn the
trade of masonry you got to go to like a
trade school like a real school yeah cuz
it's very rough for a Mason to take the
time out to teach you his trade while
he's putting up a wall or doing a job
without him knowing that you're gonna
stick with this yeah this is what you're
gonna do masonry was the hardest
apprenticeship elvis's yeah you can join
the masonry apprenticeship and that
night go to school learn how to lay
8-inch brick and block and all that
stuff but in the daytime is where you
get your hands on yeah like a hottie
like when I was filming the Rogan about
being a hottie that's one of the
toughest jobs in the world when you're
19 and you commit to being a hottie not
a roadie a hottie you're you look your
body's in a look [ __ ] sensational in
six weeks all right
yummy [ __ ] it'll be sucking your pipe
because between the Sun giving you a
suntan and you carrying Rick all day all
day
you just get tremendous shape so a guy
like me would come to you when I was 18
and go I want to be a hot carrier so you
teach me from scratch you take a bag of
cement break it 16 scoops of sand and a
half a bucket of water you have to dump
it you have to dump it mix it up in the
[ __ ] wheel bow and carry it to each
HOD carrier so let's say there's six
hunters you got a karaoke time carry us
and make sure their heart is done
they're hard and that [ __ ] cement has
to be on their board mixed and you have
to come by every three or four minutes
and put water in it and mix it the
harder it is on top of that you gotta
supply bricks you got to keep supplying
bricks so you got to pick up you got to
get one of those time
that holds eight of those bricks at once
pick them up and bring them to each
brick later ah yeah and then you go back
to make us and that's your eight-hour
day it doesn't end it does alone plus
moving lines because you wanna keep
moving the lines for them so they can
lay the brick easy it's a tough job so
to get on top the only way they can
teach you is if you get on top of it and
then sit with them for ten seconds
yeah and they'll go mean I mean that you
see this a brick here you see this a
bump see how come you take the slack hey
he do do it now oh you still [ __ ]
suck go go go back go back and do do the
sand you [ __ ] slave and they go slow
they take their time with it and now
everybody wants everything faster well
they don't take that time with it those
those Guinea bricklayers won't take that
brick from here what I'm saying form
it's an art form like itself and they
lay it things like this then they wipe
the side and wait on the next break it's
it's an art form for sure but it always
comes out perfect and now they won't
take the time now since in shooting they
won't ask you have to go to a union
thing at night and we're gonna weigh it
and go through the process and then you
become a bricklayers assistant you know
and that's a [ __ ] name and that's a
glorified hottie that means for eight
hours a day you're hot and the other
four hours a day plus you have to get
the jobsite ready for them for the next
day we talk about that a lot about
people not knowing what to expect when
they get out of school or something so
what those early jobs are the tough so
what they're doing right now they're
gonna do on this side wall so while
you're doing all this you have to dig
across that side wall to make sure that
side is even for the next day you got to
start laying their little pallets down
to see if it works
eighteen inches away from the wall see a
mess you know by to the inch you're the
first one there the lines got a wipe
down that wall but you're doing this
while that's still going on more nah
yeah that means more more [ __ ] mud
you know saying Maura Maura Maura you
have no [ __ ] idea with that what that
job is like yeah you know how first job
I had
even have [ __ ] sledgehammers you had
to do everything by hand like those one
of the electric ones oh yeah yeah they
would love you jack so you had to use a
sledgehammer sledgehammer and a [ __ ]
pick to pick it up and then you and
another gorilla picked it up and threw
in a wheelbarrow and then we rolled it
to a [ __ ] wall and then you threw it
over the [ __ ] wall that was your job
all [ __ ] day why didn't they like
jackhammers because maybe you had to get
a special permit for it maybe it was
just 12 if it was just 12 feet of
footage that you were gonna do you do
that today that's why you have these
back carries I still love sledge hammers
I love all that [ __ ] but now I don't
think that's available anymore like a
union look at ugly
oh no we looked at that there's some
sort of a mentorship program for some
local masonry so that's what you're
gonna get into no no I love hilarious
justice it was funny for such a lawful
year like before I wanted a halfway
house when I first moved to Aspen that's
what I did for two summers I did it one
summer in Jersey I didn't like I liked
another summer in Fort Lee New Jersey
Italian guy and then I did it again when
I got out of the joint I did it in
Boulder a halfway house for a guy that's
where I kept coming up positive I was
going on the jobsite snorting coke he
was having a hard time on me that's the
place where I put the [ __ ] Drano on
my dick okay you know unclog it no the
next day when I went to the job site was
when I realized my dick was bleeding oh
my god I've had a ton of my dicks up my
dicks bleeding I gotta go to a doctor
and [ __ ] how do you know it was bleeding
take a piss or solid yeah I pulled the
skin back and I saw my helmet
oh it was all bloody and me wasn't it
burning like the Drano did something to
it like I didn't know yeah yeah I did
call for that long it was for the pee
test or I would pull the skin back Oh
circumcised dick that put a chunk of
Drano in there and put the skin over it
and then when I pee I pull the skin back
and the Drano palate would Paul up fall
off into the [ __ ] baby like look
you're clean but unclog toilets
this is amazing [ __ ] up so many of
those machines they knew I was doing
something okay cuz I was like a new out
for the first time I put Drano first
time I put Drano pool cleaner mm-hmm
wait a second
like chlorine you take those little
things that you know those pellets yeah
is it chlorine the chlorine pellet okay
and people put him in a thing and they
floated around the pool to kill all the
germs I said that kills the pee doesn't
it absolutely so I took it and I grinded
it down with a hammer like a [ __ ]
rock and hoping and I had it like powder
eyes I gotta we have big buckets of them
yeah yeah it comes in either buckets or
it comes in a capsule which I wasn't
bought the capsules cuz I'm there so
obviously I smashed the [ __ ] thing
down we didn't do a bucket today
secondary I can't even imagine like
thank God is liquid now oh yeah I can't
even a because you were doing powder
I don't like I've never even seen a
powder but that can't be good you've
never seen a powder a no no no one likes
you it's alright it's a little container
like that it's a circle and you pour it
over okay Jack do the whole thing like a
jacks oh you've seen a jack okay I've
seen it but I wouldn't put up on my dick
well you're not as exciting as us that's
why oh my god I pour it in my dick no
[Music]
burns what's that I would wipe that I
would wipe to help it off with no
moisture yeah and I would let's say it
let's say I had a pee right now like I'd
pull up here and I'd put that supply
take my dick out in the car and put the
drain on my dick then okay
I'd secure a little chunk to it to the
bottom of my dick when I pull the skin
over so wouldn't fall on the way the pee
test and I would take the skin from the
deck and put it upward towards my belt
so it would be tied to something I don't
[ __ ] around
no I would walk up the stairs I would do
the paperwork and then he'd make me go
in the bathroom and there'd be mirrors
on top of the toilet and to the sides
and he would stand outside so all I
would do is take my dick out
pull the skin back and pee in the thing
I'd see the chip fall into the okay to
the thing what did you start like
bubbling out right off the [ __ ] back
oh my god it was making a weird noise
and closed it and there's something else
I put on my dick there was a couple
things I put to try the drain oh shut me
down the drain Oh was the last one
that's it
that's such a bad chemical that's like
putting that kind of chemical on your
dick is so bad I can't even imagine I
mean I don't have it there that you're
addicted you do it I guess you're right
but I I have friends that we try
everything when they had to take a test
like that drug test try everything drink
this drink that drink Clorox an idiot
rank chloride I used to drink these kids
think they're cool with tie pots no I
used to drink not I used to drink white
vinegar white vinegar white vinegar
would that help at all not I mean I'm
just curious I'm embarrassed to even
tell the story and I know because I know
my friends would try every [ __ ] thing
I try because you know what you put in
jello to make it thick there's an other
thing so no Sarah I tried zinc because
if you eat a bunch of zinc you get by
your body gets hot yeah there's
something that makes your body sting I
did that this was way before a headshot
this is 87 and I was doing the war this
is before the work what vitamins work
because you have vitamin sometimes you
take a vitamin very 88 to 91
good night men three years of piss test
that for no reason because it didn't do
anything it didn't deter my drug use
right it just taught me how to break the
system it just taught me how to fool a
[ __ ] assist yeah well I see you're
learning something at least it's not
like it's that didn't teach you anything
or didn't you no no no because it just
taught me how to work around the system
I have become such a dormitory it's not
a sneak but I knew I could get high
Friday nights yeah okay I knew I could
get hot Friday nights I got that
judicial system didn't do much for me at
the time because I wasn't really ready
to get you know whatever the [ __ ] the
word is yeah probably get huh you mean
like clean yeah like I didn't want to
stop doing drugs I would guess I kind of
bullying huh
not [ __ ] bull we gotta get the party
started no no I love this toy I know
edible because I got [ __ ] to do tonight
oh okay I wasn't even gonna bring it up
I'll take you forgot about the animal
zoo
what are you forgetting I got like ten
pieces in the [ __ ] bag we're gonna
sink your ship but that means I [ __ ]
myself up tonight doing I got plans for
that I got things to do in people's
lands I'll do some [ __ ] so no no it
didn't really take me at all would ya it
made me work around the system Eleanor
like I know you have bred vets and it it
really sucks like I wasted my time and
their time yeah like I wish they would
have like taking a survey afterwards or
something years later and something push
that away from them before you depo is a
little noise jacket you know I wish they
would've took a survey to see whatever
systems they had worked because they
didn't deter me at all but they were
true that is what they were trying to do
scare you with the pizza I thought is to
keep you from losing a job now so just
ignore this test
oh no jobs didn't really I bested my
friends all have them bear side with
hate evil amen
they were maybe it was a 92 right then
they really got hip to it know if you're
a mailman you can't get high my friends
on show him and he can't get high man
get [ __ ] high but again you get
huiling on a Friday and really be cool
it's the THC yeah that citizen yeah I
don't know how long opiate staying in
blood for I don't know either I don't I
don't do drugs I suck at life I
should've never done a drug not yes not
all of them what made you not do drugs
ah me my brother Billy were very young I
think we ride in big wheels that's how
young and we saw a guy overdose like a
neighborhood kid who was like he was a
big basketball star he was gonna be
everything and we watched him fall and
he just started foaming at the mouth and
he just started come and I was like oh
my god uh and my brother Jimmy who's
nine years older than us was like get
out of here get home so he kicked us out
but me and Billy kept watching and I
watched this kid and then Jimmy saw us
again and he goes that's what that's
what happens if you do drugs and we I
was like oh [ __ ] so I got scared and get
and this guy's whole life was ruined
he is from he didn't die but his brain
didn't come back right and to this day
he walks in our neighborhood and every
time I bring people in my neighborhood
that don't know him they get scared of
him they're like hey that guy I'm like
nah that's cool that's Gary he's cool
he's he's fine you all hurt no no never
recovered and today he'll take steps and
step back you know he's one of those
he's been in halfway houses his whole
life his parents kicked him out drugs he
was every Scott a basketball scholarship
they were coming every college was after
him he [ __ ] everything up and it just
scared me I was like oh [ __ ] but it
didn't stop my brother Billy he did it
he does him sometimes I don't know if he
still does am I gonna say that I
probably just low pond stuff no no they
got crafty Charlie's uh my brother
Charlie likes to drink he's been
drinking since the sixth grade
full-blown alcoholic but he doesn't care
that's what he does he still works pays
his rent that's it that's it he's not
bothering nobody
and I have nothing against those people
at all I like people were very honest
with themselves do you know later this
is what I didn't go to work they put 25
a week for drinking of yes that you
can't they give to the house whatever
that to contribute and the rest goes to
Charlie's grill that's right on the
corner and you don't want to go anywhere
else
guess what you can't get him to go to
another bar that's right they don't want
to go to another bar if you have to go
to another bar it's the worst thing in
the world it would kill them and
sometimes they do for a change of pace I
think on Saturday mornings whoa they
meet the guys who work over a different
bar and watch college football and I
don't know I'd never put that lifestyle
down
I just wasn't for me it's not it's tough
cuz it to be very honest growing up like
yeah if I had to if I have to think
about it I probably did put that life
like it's not there's nothing like
glamour to me there's nothing there was
nothing nothing glamorous about that
level our to it for sure but now like
you grew up in the wrong neighborhood
that's true but seeing like now growing
up and seeing just listening to that
Elton John song at the beginning I was
never a music person but now that I've
had relationships you start like oh I
see what's going on when people listen
to music when you see adults and you're
like you know what maybe they just they
stayed too long at that shitty job and
and this is how they survive and it's
it's it's it would be easier to be more
empathetic now I think I think that
it's when somebody accepts their
position mm-hmm which always has shocked
me and at the same time made me happy
yeah there's people accept that position
this is what they do
yeah and this is what they're gonna do
and this is how they live and they're
very proud of that they're very proud
yeah hey so I give those people all the
props and the fall the crops I love
people like that thing you know like I
had that [ __ ] crazy Vietnam buddy in
Boulder he lived like in a [ __ ]
Vietnam Nest like he thought he was
still in Vietnam yeah that leaves on the
wall ah [ __ ] but once I got to know all
those years it's here is when I saw him
I knew who he was but when I went
through his apartment I really got to
know
like that was the simplest way down like
you see what makes people tick yeah what
that's a thing people immediately shut
somebody out like if they see a guy like
that or my friend back home they
immediately go oh no he looks [ __ ] up
we're not gonna talk to them no matter
what that their house is all dingy don't
talk to them those sometimes are the
greatest people in the world they're
just going through some [ __ ] I can't get
out of a rut whatever it is they're not
hurt nobody except themselves when I
come here before I come here depends
what route I go I stop at 7-eleven this
7-eleven doesn't have cigarettes Naoto
what because they sold [ __ ]
cigarettes in London minor so I gotta go
here for my nicotine gum this point over
here is a weird one because there's a
lot of old there's a black guy every
time I see him I throw him a 20 okay
just fit just him what cuz you had a
conversation with him made of scene I
made a decision about between a bums
he's the I understood his journey well
in my head I paint like there's another
guy that takes bottles mm-hmm
so I always give me three bottles in the
dollar mmm okay and I have my reasoning
with him because he's not looking for
money looking for bottles he's got a bag
of bottles that's all he does is walk
around all day and grab [ __ ]
recyclable bottles
I gotta respect that guy yeah you know
he's not looking for a him I just gonna
whatever bottles you got the [ __ ] car
and I see more people give him bottles
in the dollar and the guys are just
standing out there going can I have a
dollar
can I have changed I can I see a kid
asking me for change like them to [ __ ]
off 24 on the green 43 I come the [ __ ]
off now I understand mental health yeah
now the black guy I see I got very many
reasons first of all he's six foot four
mm-hmm 265 if I'm ever walking in this
neighborhood and I got a problem and
that [ __ ] guy ocz he's good but
you're right you could tell he's got the
strength of 10 [ __ ] jobs
yeah we'll be there he's got the two
strength of ten black dudes and I've
spoken to him and I've looked in his
eyes he's got a little bit of mental
health but gonna tell what the other
part of it is just Kayla he just wanted
to be happy yeah I see him walking
smoking a cigarette listen to music yeah
bouncing and I go you know what I wish I
had that happiness right just woke up in
a cave the ultimate happiness you know I
just woke up in a cave and I'm worried
about my bills I'm wearing my my
daughter I'm wearing my my wife and
there's all good things but look at that
guy
no worries that guy was a Southern
California in a park around here
somewhere
he looks like The Wolfman he dresses up
a Denny's cousin I was a dealing at
Denny's the baby likes Denny's possible
that she likes breakfast for dinner oh
so I got a same thing at the turkey club
when I see him come in and on the way I
call him over to a table and give him a
20 and the people dead he's look at me
like he ain't sitting there yeah he's on
his way but don't worry about nothing
but at least he knows up my wife and
daughter look like I am I tell my wife
told me one day I saw him I say I saw
you boy and I game ten bucks
I go why and she goes because there's a
lot of times I'm walking there same
thing I got a problem
that's why no Tarzan will come over and
kill I'm surprised you haven't given him
your address just they'll kill him don't
kill him those homeless dudes that
dude's got the strength of ten bears
always friends with homeless food Bruce
moved to LA I've used but I know it was
a con man oh yeah it was a [ __ ] you
knew the [ __ ] kid that hangs out
that always goes up from the church but
he's homeless he's home was as well
well you gotta could tell he's just out
there drinking I gave him money one time
but I could tell that the first time he
bull should've made Tommy he's trying he
sleeps by the library
okay he breaks into a library gate he
sleeps from there on the floor every day
when I moved here I would walk to the
Comedy Store on Sunset from Sunset
Martell to the Comedy Store I knew every
homeless person and sometimes when
people would donate thanks to the Comedy
Store like a lot of comics would bring
like old clothes and stuff and nobody
wanted them I would give them to the
homeless guys on the way there was one
lady and all mostly men
Mary whose to sit outside rock'n'roll
Ralphs all the time I got a different
homeless guy to that he he lives over on
Chandler and he's he was like under the
brother that that bridge no no have you
go if you go from Cahuenga
I think oh hell enough to walk to hunger
to Colfax he lives on that little bridge
I'm him now rich is there but he comes
out of the daytime he goes into the
jungle at night and he's got a cart with
hubcaps he won't take a dime from you oh
he'll take food and clothes so I bring
him close
oh that's interesting say I dig them
clothes and food do you don't it's the
other way they get if you don't know no
no no he doesn't want nothing from
nobody it's very interesting the
different personalities you know you've
gotta have to go home at time to go if I
was homeless house you know a nice -
well I [ __ ] go to a shelter would I
live outside I mean that if I learn oh
yeah well you can't go to a shelter you
just have to behave they will kick you
out yeah you can't you get there by a
certain point you sign up but I used to
hang out with the homeless all the time
I used to feel bad when I first moved
here I was really naive and not naive
but I would feel bad I was like how the
hell are these people survive it's so
high have no idea I know it was the lady
Mary her legs were so swollen from the
Sun we used to break my heart then I'd
see her at the bank I'm like this [ __ ]
out of the bank account but you knew she
had a family and she just like somehow
gave up or whatever the [ __ ] she did I
don't know and then Angelo when I would
give him clothes I remember giving him
shoes from my first ex-fiancée's brother
who was very wealthy and he goes these
aren't my [ __ ] size and he throw him
down and I was like you know what do you
want from me like they have nice shoes
that they're like top of the lining put
him on he's like they're not my guys and
he would freak out but then if I give
him a sandwich he'd be fine you don't I
mean like never asked me for money but
every time I come around they go my
trunk and [ __ ] and see what I have not a
bad way just check it out but they all
of them will go to shelters except for
Mary she liked to stay outside a
Catholic woman
believing my most of your feel like
pulling over and just sucking one of
their dicks it was a handsome one guy
had a swollen nut cookie cookie well how
did they do that that's the other thing
there's only a few homeless women we
gotta take them all and bathe them oh I
got a baby I can show y'all taking home
Jim the extra string soap son we wanted
to clean the shower after workers work I
tried to bring one home my mom gum
there's one I saw I totally I want
whenever I go to Hollywood I go to that
bagel place across from the griddle on
Sunset yes it's a very good dog good Sam
they make a piece of sandwich the bagel
they're all the same and don't matter
but there's a chick in there I saw one
today there was a homeless as [ __ ] and
she was a tent she was one of those
girls that came here do you remember the
girl that used to go to the Comi store
they used to wear a wig Thomas really
pretty and she got involved with a bunch
of black guys I think they even they did
something to her at The Comedy Store one
day Oh
a while ago a mrs. Rowe was the key
there was a black kid that used to hang
out with Eddie Griffin okay he wasn't
famous his father was famous yeah a
writer he had a few shows on the air and
he would come into the store and he had
something to do with that guy they did
something to her one night she feel like
I know who you're talking about night
really good-looking and she would come
to the store on Sundays to watch with a
wig and she befriended me one night
there at the store and we started
talking and I think she was really a
hooker probably with mental problems and
I would see her on Sunset with like
different wigs on every day [ __ ]
different wing hood she might have been
out there help in the hall was really
weird how many mint
while people of course you come across
at the Comedy Store
especially on Sunday nights like the
people that are really you have to be
nervous about what was a kid that they
said I threw him out I never threw him
under they do the documentary about him
the old guy they used to come here but
crispy chicken Mickey there's a million
of them we talk about we talk about him
all the time on the comedy start a
podcast I used to break my balls Oh was
it a machine ripped or like a Gaylord
Gaylord Engler big yeah I'm a she ripped
her leg off unless she I had to quit
Sunday's because I started learning the
[ __ ] mental illness acts like I would
know their stand-up in an hour and they
thought it was me who killed them
because if somebody said he died
somebody said Mickey killed him this
older guy Mickey who he used to hang out
with and they said he killed him he beat
him up he left him for dead and that
wasn't true he was he was back with his
family so I don't know who made up that
[ __ ] rumor but they probably do too I
had a fight with him when then that a
fistfight no you can I fall with it was
like uh you will have the list I commies
know what the names and yeah the muscle
is away okay Lord stopping you're not on
the list you better check that list man
I better check my last [ __ ] how we
gonna get Lord I'm looking at it right
now to find your [ __ ] name I'll give
you five hours [ __ ] list it's not a
Mentalist and one night we had an
argument about son I told Gayle get the
[ __ ]
I've had enough this [ __ ] particularly
[ __ ] from you for years you know he was
a hold of guy so I felt like not a case
not really bad and one man I just had to
tell him to go [ __ ] himself and then he
would show up to threaten me yeah a
fight I don't know he was always
threatening me and one day I think I
grabbed him something happened I told my
said really kill me kill me but stop
lurking up you get the [ __ ] out of here
and then that was it
I never heard about
Gaylord NY forgot the name and one day
when my school space becomes poppy I got
a hit on my face normally I want to
interview me for a documentary about
what happened to Gaylord Daniel is
missing [ __ ] kill nobody
I forget who did it but yeah I do with
Todd Bunsen that the documentary baby
[ __ ] time something out at the store
they lift that kid on fire one night
okay
the Judah kid that comes at night and
then you mix the SWAT stickers that goes
like this that was a funny comic and he
got into a car accident and Mitzi told
me to close out the show provided he
used to light him on fire the [ __ ]
bathroom and they would show paper in
the fire and it broke they would slow
pay though with fire on and then lock
them in there and he'd be in there help
help help
[ __ ] lay them on fire the Nazis are
trying to kill me and even do the thing
with the Nazi he would go like this
little put the little mustache over it
like they're trying to get me the Nazis
he called the naughty ones I'm not a
[ __ ] Nazi I'm cute stop it
I used to get annoyed from these guy
someone who has special properties
special because is a generation listen
raise the hose from 8th to 10th at North
End 11th old guys got there yeah then I
quit then I relinquish my spot yes I
would put two people up dice you ready
job sick a host of yeah I'm ready do
whatever you do - I was really yeah 18
common something well I've got a spot in
here waiting for a spot and I would
invite them all up but what they didn't
know is I was also called ice or Eddie
Griffin or Rogan and tell them to get
down there I got a nice spot for them
they do two or three hours and these
guys would be waiting I'm going on Eddie
with you three are their families and
everything and I would bring [ __ ] and
honey down there there's still comics
out there who blame you for like yeah
Joey didn't let me go they wouldn't
blame Joey nicer as a woman that still
walks around till today and says that
she missed her cable show because I
wouldn't switch Botwin
and it's her career outside of the shut
your I just ran into her I can't believe
you brought her name ups I don't even
know I still hear from people about said
because you would switch spots with her
she didn't get a spot on the major
league team people he wants me to do her
show and I am going to do it and then
bring her up that she would have been
gigantic if Joe Diaz did not had
switched at switch spot she would have
been the biggest comic guys if things
wouldn't work out as they did I would
have left here and said you don't want
listen to spider-man - I got into The
Longest Yard I proved my point and then
a couple shows I got into the stand I
got a Miss he shows yeah but what ruined
my life was doing drugs like that that
was it I'm not gonna lie to you and I at
times I still feel I could have done
more but those first 17 years of doing
coke in the beginning then you know I
accept my faith an amazing bounce back
by the shirt weight coked up to the
gills waving him happy big spider man to
coax up to the girls all those things
coked up to the gills and nobody do
nothing to follow and Rogan and Paul
Mooney and distorts right not talked up
to the girls you know afterward I get
coked up to the guilty but yeah you did
a lot considering if you ask me what
happened joy when I'm 85 they live in a
[ __ ] bedroom apartment and kids you
know kids throw a ball behind your back
yard yeah wait a second well you know
one of my favorite movies and you show
me a movie posters you know you still
live in this town yeah you know it's
like where have you gone for that sag
place I've been Woodland Hills were old
people with go up that dog right there
and say you want to do an interview
you'll be there for two years because
those are all people I thought they
wanted to do is talk they're actors from
the [ __ ] 40s that's the great idea
and they got stories to tell they'll
tell you about the Formosa when they
blew John Wayne yeah nobody wife well
yet was a sexual assault was a way of
life here you know they got stories up
there so can you am I
like mobility a grandfather and him
wanted to tell you if it can look me in
the face and said mr. Diaz do you think
you could have been his biggest louis
c.k what were the reasoning is why you
didn't might say the Mamas mama one
reason we visit all that [ __ ] I did
although she is you know it just plus I
was 32 when I moved there was a lot of
variables and in fact it really doesn't
matter many lottery anyway but if you
sit there and saying it's a cable show
that's a [ __ ] problem like a [ __ ]
prop that's it that's a mental I was
thinking of daily spilling the other day
mom bless his soul what did you rest his
soul yes isn't it Danny Brown I saw
Danny Stone stone I saw Danny stone was
a comic at the Comedy Store
he only did Rodney that was there
through all those years he did a great
Rodney impression and that was his whole
act and that was his whole life but he
was a good-looking guy he was date when
I first met see here's the beauty of
that guy he would look you straight in
the face and tell you that Rodney ruined
his career so I would sit there and go
so wait a second so Rodney called every
comedy club individually and said not to
hire you because you didn't impress
impression of him that's all he did
that's all he did but it doesn't matter
Rodney's not gonna take the time all
across the country to go hey don't hire
him no more because he's doing an
impression of me but nobody's gonna hire
him because that's all he does there's
no segways there's nothing there's no
him because he did coke all the [ __ ]
time
well that's it that's why I didn't hire
you know you have to be honest with
yourself as a stand-up you have to be
honest yourself as an individual why am
I not getting the opportunities these
guys are getting yeah I got the
opportunities I got him - bloom bloom
that was it
at least be honest but don't sit there
and blame it on well jewel
came out with a song that year
and I went to a party and I called her a
[ __ ] now nobody wants to hire me that's
a lie
it's all bull big [ __ ] what's-his-name
in a suit jerking off with a Batman suit
on and look now he's winning Academy
Awards knees Iron Man yeah this town
forgives number one there's a lot if
unless you if you have what to back it
up with if you have something back it up
with and if you're sincerely apologetic
and get help
yeah they don't give a [ __ ] I can't wait
for Lois special to come out you think
oh absolutely working out already
correct I don't know about that but I've
been showing up the club I believe it
would happen it's all he could do it's
only knows how to do other than be
creepy and you know do that kind of [ __ ]
and I thought I hadn't heard any
allegations against Lois for a long long
time so I just assumed he was getting
help his wife left him [ __ ] happen in
his life yeah he was succeeding but at
the same time I thought he was getting
help and then everything comes out and
his career goes away so I think it like
Lois defense he got away from Becky and
I don't think Becky did anything wrong
truly is that weird of me to say I what
I think is Louie got to him first
you don't I mean like when that happened
in Aspen and those girls went running to
tell hey he did this and are in in his
room you know we were sitting there with
clothes and whatever they went they
[ __ ] told like you're supposed to do
everybody got like oh we're going to
[ __ ] March for you we're gonna and
then when they Louie got to Becky first
and he said these girls I tried to [ __ ]
around with them they didn't want to now
they're [ __ ] trying to ruin my
marriage
he didn't tell him specifically what he
did I'm positive he didn't especially
that first time because for somebody to
go out on a limb to defend you like that
if he did something that stupid
you know I mean you would want to keep
it real quiet he made a stink Becky he
[ __ ] yelled at everybody too bad
Louie's doing this you're trying to ruin
his marriage knock it the [ __ ] off you
know what I mean maybe later
he caught on Becky but I don't think
he's an accomplice like they're like his
career should go Louie should go this
one should go you
I'm saying what he did was creepy Louis
I want the names of the agents that sent
all those girls
- Harvey Clinton you know everyone's
right their pimps their [ __ ] know
exactly what's happening you know it was
great the morning after the [ __ ]
Golden Globes they posted all these
pictures of Harvey one stay nanopore and
him kissing you oh these people are
disgusting if you're listening at home
you live in Ohio whatever yeah and
you're sitting there going 40 listen to
me stay where you are
they're all scumbags at least you have
humans around yo these people have
feelings they look at you and they you
know I have dealt with criminals that
have more decency yeah these [ __ ]
people I deal with on a daily basis okay
I trust them as far as I could throw
them that'll give a [ __ ] I keep doing
the podcast I keep doing my stand-up I
do like to control yeah I agree I mean I
think I'm thrilled that women are
standing up for themselves and being
heard absolutely some people are going a
little too crazy with it but and it's
undermining the real [ __ ] problems
that we need like this Aziza sorry [ __ ]
did you read that one I'm not a big fan
of his but that's that's just a bad date
[ __ ] you got to learn that's just you
[ __ ] up you may have been so you suck
the dick what an Indian once you suck a
dick that's twice the party's over
twice nobody forced you to do as you
want you suck a dick if I do a
reach-around I'm tickling your [ __ ]
or finger your ass we're in the middle
of something give me permission yeah
oops yeah you don't I mean cut it it
well I knew this was gonna happen
listen I'm a guy who I was 40 years ago
I'm a way different person who I was 30
years ago and I'm waiting to prison who
I was 20 years ago
you cannot come out of the woodwork now
and say that 23 years ago I took it to a
hotel room put a [ __ ] rock in your [ __ ]
or something like that you cannot you
can act that was me then this is now I
don't buy it you know for Dustin Hoffman
wanted a foot rub in the end 78 or
whatever the [ __ ] it is yeah somebody's
crotch that I cannot live with that I
can listen somebody does something to
you raise your [ __ ] head
if you're not fearful that it wasn't all
that bad if I pull a knife on you
al-anon you make an ally you call 9-1-1
you'll always never call your brother
you call somebody they would leave I
pull a gun on Lea and I'm going to shoot
you
Lea runs on e it calls the cops what's
different when I put my dick on you oh
why because I'm in the position of power
this has been going on for centuries
those sag ladies whatever power you know
what I feel bad for all these people but
I feel bad for Marilyn Monroe Marilyn
Monroe for they passed her around like a
[ __ ] piece of bread
he's like when you load Italians dinner
and they get the bread and passed around
they passed her around like a piece of
[ __ ] bread dog and they do this to
all these girls they know this [ __ ] they
know who's I ain't knows not you know
Wendy knowing when when the Dean when
[ __ ] Harvey Weinstein calls the black
dude and the director yeah got in
trouble together what's their names are
you talking about
Woody Allen no okay okay whatever his
name is doesn't matter when he calls her
mother saw you having a party who's
going on this one this law she's gonna
be that little [ __ ] you know
they've been doing this for you sure I
reckon I want the list of the chicks
that did suck his dick to get a movie
yeah you know that's what I do want
that's what I'm interested in aren't
complaining I'm not though I'm at the
end of it and at the end of the [ __ ]
Road
I think half these chicks suck this dick
you saw all the tapes of them thanking
you we also mm-hmm we live in this
apakah this city right here is a walking
[ __ ] hypocrisy absolutely I see it in
people we don't know we see it amongst
the people we do know and it's such a
hypocritical city that it makes you sick
to your stomach if you have a heartbeat
or if you were raised with any type of
[ __ ] yeah if you were raised they
type of normal environment this is all
out of whack to you all right sound a
lot to me it's but the thing is like I I
don't like when people say it only
exists in Hollywood it doesn't it does
exist everywhere there's they're creeps
everywhere you don't I mean like a
friend he's like this pedophilia
only in Hollywood only in Hollywood and
I'm like dude we got a church ever
two of our priests okay well we're all
you know I mean it's [ __ ] everywhere
I'm just saying pay attention look out
raise your kids [ __ ] make them be
aware it's so my mom told us about that
[ __ ] we were kids she also told us
nobody wanted us so don't flatter
yourself nobody's trying to finger in
the back of the kid your mom has to sit
you down yes at the Everett daughter
especially I don't again and talk you
again and talk to you again and bring it
up again and I've never heard of things
till I left what yeah I never heard of
such things you know the girls the
parents where I grew up the parents were
tight with the girls the girls won't
watch you know I grew up very naive
there was a lot of girls I went to high
school with my never [ __ ] that I heard
Mao was sucking dick with three hands
and sprayed you know I'm gonna do that
we show that a good girl yeah I'm the
one that always showed up that nobody
wanted to [ __ ] after they [ __ ] a guy
they're really [ __ ] 18 guys and now
they went to church ate the cookie now
they're gonna change no I decided to
take him out on a date you know say look
though we didn't want to suck dick no
yeah the week I think but it's true it's
like we grew up a different way I mean
my I was fortunate I had five older
brothers you know what I mean and we
were tight and they would tell me you
know if somebody does this you punch him
in the [ __ ] face like will come ten
million yeah you don't need to go the
cops just come tell us the whole family
was fine I don't you know and they were
all did listen even the actors there's
girls that booklet
every actor goes to a city for something
mmm yeah yeah will you go and this
there's a little more entitlement here's
well no entitlement honey wouldn't you
go to Minneapolis and you're in a hotel
and there's a girl there that is a fan
of yours there's a fan something you do
you know how easy it is to take
advantage of that girl ten years younger
than you you're a movie star and they've
all done it yeah
they've all know that's why they're all
right
right now they're hoping these girls
forget they're hoping these girls forget
it was too long though everybody goes to
a town yeah and some innocent girl comes
up to you have you really been on TV and
right away it removes everything oh yeah
they put you on a different type of
pedestal and you take your dick out they
suck I mean it's [ __ ] you know I same
it happens to me all the time you were
saying you were saying earlier that this
town can be forgiving and I like it I
think it can but to me what I learned
since being here is that they'll forgive
you and this could be everyone but it's
all about money you're a beautiful man
there you go it's gotta be forgiving and
you have to show up on an envelope
that's gonna be forgiven you have to put
money in their pocket again so they
understand they're forgiving you know in
1993 and 1995 I was not charged I was
accused of sexual harassment okay a girl
in a comedy club said I grabbed her ass
I did not say that fine and dandy I took
it like a man I knew I had I knew my
intentions weren't bad right she was
running towards me and I jumped and
grabbed her ass you know like when she
jumped got at if you heard better than
the comedy work she walk on I guess she
ran down the stairs she's like Joey and
she jumped and I held onto ass she she
did not complain I managing that that
was also a comic at my level me and him
we're running neck in that case oil
pulled her aside and said to her you
should press charges for Joey
there was no charges pressed they told
the club manager and I was banned for
life one of the best things that ever
happened because I had decided when I
won this was why stay in Denver with two
shitty clubs yeah you can't do the
comedy works but that's not fun yeah
yeah
decision I got the [ __ ] out of there 20
years later I met that [ __ ] festival
Wow the big festival with Dave Chappelle
she was there she was how are you Wendy
the Aspen no the other I ball hard ball
up aw okay Wendy comes up angle great do
you hate me if I go no as a matter of
fact I love you because if you ain't
would have thrown me out I was a still
be limbo girl humping it being a [ __ ]
stiff yeah she was what do you mean I
explained my situation I know you didn't
know what I was going through at that
time I was going through a war my
ex-wife right now I was ready to kill
her so you will do that keep me alive
you throw me out of the club made me who
I am today
yeah I had never sexually harassed
nobody if I would if I would have done
that you would have heard it a thousand
times
she was you're absolutely right quote
have your agent call me get a date for
me a gal but he talks and [ __ ] walks
that's right because she knows you're
gonna bring money into the club if she
knows what I did was [ __ ] it was bad
I said 20 years ago but I didn't have a
leg to stand on it was part of the bad
luck that I was going through yeah I was
going through a bunch of bad things at
the time divorce no money I was getting
taking the court I was frustrated if
there's a comedy I was broke that was
part of the [ __ ] thing that toughened
me up and look it proved it
I'm not [ __ ] sexual assault Lu on
your face I want to think you're very
open and that's a thing like we work in
comedy clubs you know like at the Comedy
Store I can't remember being in a
meeting about sexual like if they're you
know they have to give the pamphlets out
like hey if this happens during work you
know the HR people like Comedy Store
doesn't really have HR people but
especially back when we were dead years
and I remember they were handing out
things and the poor manager was trying
to read the [ __ ] pamphlet out loud
like this if this happens because the
guy was there watching to make sure we
had the meeting and as they were doing
the meeting we were all standing in the
kitchen and I was like leaning with my
ass out where that service entrance is
in the kitchen and one of the comics
came in and right in the middle of this
[ __ ] speech he smacks me right in the
ass and he goes no Dave Tyree same [ __ ]
I love Dave
but the I go
I stood up and I went I think this
meetings over okay
hi Dave we laughed so hard he had no
idea what the [ __ ] we were doing he just
thought we were just smiles everybody
standing in the kitchen but he hit me so
hard it just vibrated through the whole
[ __ ] room stay we had a blast
so it was like what is that a sexual
assault no that's funny that's comedy
it's enough I mean we knew each other we
were very good friends I had a girl it
flappers tell me the last time I saw you
grab my [ __ ] and I looked I see now if
he did that you're like the face listed
first off I didn't grab your [ __ ] and
number two don't [ __ ] ever repeat
something that [ __ ] groupid this had it
be back to you it was right after mercy
was born oh Jesus I love to flap his own
name she was the social media girl okay
I was very nice to his bill Jim
Jefferies okay we were talking to her
the whole day and I guess she gets
hammered and someone her Hammond mum and
she said I grabbed the puss I was like
no I don't don't repeat that
yes the whole even [ __ ] know you and
we had little become friends and [ __ ]
she ended up work I have the store for a
while she quit that through Sarah Sarah
dresses
oh yeah yes I like her but yes she
definitely has some mental some problems
yeah she's funny too [ __ ] I feel sad
because I wish I saw her more because
she's one you know you root for these
women that are [ __ ] really funny
not just women who are like I'm a woman
and nobody hires me and that's why I'm
not working no [ __ ]
we need [ __ ] hardcore funny comics
out there you know that they really get
together this thing against the store
and it's all these women that couldn't
get arrested in [ __ ] Sin City and
they torment the store they look at the
lineups every night maisonette yeah and
its first off it's women that wouldn't
get spots at the store
and the good thing about me is I stole
all those lineups from when I was a
regular and then the [ __ ] bangies
good for you and it was the same about a
woman in the lineups when Mitzi was
there um I I do believe Missy worked
with more because this is the thing
Mitzi did the main room and she did it
as a variety show so if you notice in
the main room it would be Janis
heart-opening I don't even know if you
remember that name these are like the
90s and then it would be Argus in the
9:15 spot 915 cross the board Argus cot
and that it would be another Monica
gayness who was more of a character kind
of a thing and it was kind of like the
warm up and then it would go Cap'n era
Mulrooney Moony like that kind of it
would get into the stand up stand ups
Sherri Shepherd's wreath of Jones you
know what I mean they were and they used
to complain sherry and wreaths used to
complain where at the back of the lineup
and it's because we're black I was like
no no you like look what's happening
like it's she's it's a variety show Val
Pappas they were singing they did weird
characters you know what I mean and
that's what Mitzi saw that big main room
ass she wanted it to be a variety show
and nobody ever got it I knew it because
I was her assistant so she would [ __ ]
tell me on a regular basis so then when
the girls Paulie got mad at Monica
gayness he was like you believe my mom
still books that [ __ ] and so Monica
stopped coming
Val Pappas they just got older it just
became a weird thing and it just faded
out and then sherry and wreaths and
moved up because those kind of things
faded out and it became a regular comic
comedy list you don't I mean there was
no more singers and dancers and [ __ ]
and not that it's [ __ ] they were
funny they did a great job it was just
not what you want to see that kid James
T was a thirsty was a turd Paul Mooney
column yeah the other guy that used to
sing that still in Vegas good-looking
black guy - Anderson this had this
beautiful voice beautiful voice yes she
liked that that was her it was her
variety show and then the
original rule was your Ricker's your
raime Ollie's you know they were Mitzi's
babies Tommy Davidson
and it was a mix of every the upstairs
the belly room belly room was at that
point when I got there was already into
the bringer kind of thing not bring her
but produced shows outside produce shows
and Mitzie did prefer it if you were a
paid regular who wanted to run a certain
show up there but early she put all the
women up there to get him ready to come
down to make him strong for Jean and
then what happened was they got so
popular up there that like LeBeau and
those guys would go up there and be like
hey man we want to be up here because
she would put the overflow from the
original room in the belly room the the
paint you know the paying customers so
then the girls would perform for them
and the room got so hot they were like
now we'd rather stay up here this is
great and they wouldn't go downstairs so
it got hot and all the [ __ ] guy
comics were like we would have come up
here so Mitzi started weeding him in and
it just happened naturally but she
didn't want them to get buried down
there wasn't that she didn't like women
people always say that omits he wasn't
for women [ __ ] yes she won't pull
[ __ ] [ __ ] you she did the women of The
Comedy Store she did it on the Playboy
channel for years Tamayo Sookie nobody
in their right mind would have taken a
shot on Tamayo
Sookie no nowhere in the world she
barely spoke English and Mitzi was
halfway had her to being a superstar but
she's a little bit of a mental patient
she that didn't work out but she was up
there she was climbing up she always had
women's shows always check used to come
when I first got there she used to have
the chick that would show up and have
the pajama parties what was her name she
had a show on USA lately Oh Rhonda Shear
Rhonda Shear Rhonda Shear billionaire by
the way who'd [ __ ] sit there and
watch all these hot broads walk past
your pajamas on I'm wearing her sports
bra right now as we speak
going into the main room
and she would have a night with Rhonda
Shear babies and they would [ __ ]
drink in there did she do it on the
Playboy channel she did something
something well it's real interesting how
every time I talk to a woman that and
then look at the spots it's not that
many spots for women first of all I see
I will know there I see the chick that
response Constance my favorite Sarah
Tiana yeah first of all if we have a ton
of female comics I see Jessica myself
singleton Jessica Michelle singleton
terrific we have a ton of female comics
they're all working Morgan Murphy
fortune teams they're on the road all
the [ __ ] Ali Wong she's out on the
road she's working when a girl is good
pregnant yeah she might she might be in
labor right now actually really wrong no
she's on her second kid for sure but the
last time I saw her she was I forget how
long far along she was I want to thank I
will up congratulate Crispin Crispian
position Tom get ready to on the road
and sit that the ice grows roots you
won't even come to be coming home on
Mondays and Tuesdays no more cuz you
don't know what's worse coming over the
two kids and a wife that has the same
day like the month or being on the road
constantly you just bought yourself a
key to hell tap out at two-man cap out
it oh my god cuz one is tough one you
could I could go on the road and she
could leave for the weekend yeah - you
don't wanna volunteer for that job as a
manual you know what I guess I'm going
to Des Moines was was was the end at
that depth kid [ __ ]
that's tough and that's another thing by
the way for anybody male or female if
you're a decent parent to do this
business and be a parent like Tom and
Christina have it mapped out that mapped
out that was for one [ __ ] kid well
yeah now that is smell
that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] her
special was great that she just did
Christine this is great that just came
the and they'll just keep working they
work together but that's how strong you
have to be to get on those lineups leave
the comedy stores like McDonald's
everybody serves [ __ ] meat but they
always pick on McDonald's they're the
problem McDonald did go to any other
fast-food it's the same [ __ ] right so if
you go to the Comedy Store and you're
saying I'm not seeing any women go to
the Laugh Factory it's all men fine [ __ ]
it once in a while I get in there Kate
Quigley as a few but we have more spots
at the comedy store to give out because
we have more rooms Jamie only has the
one little [ __ ] room so if you notice
his lineups are men but it's [ __ ] big
working comics and they put asses in the
seats and in the end of this day at the
end of the day this is a [ __ ]
business and if you're not pointing
asses in the seats you and get in spots
[ __ ] that's just how it works
you don't mean like if you look at our
lineups at the store it's you it's Rogan
it's Neal Brennan
it's [ __ ] Tom Segura it's Aliyah
D'Elia
it's Ian Edwards it's I mean insane
Steve Byrne it's [ __ ] you gotta be
beating the [ __ ] when you get on that
lineup like if I get a spot at 12:15 the
person before me and after me is killing
that room if you're not killing that
[ __ ] room you ain't get on that's
just how it goes I mean the older female
comics that are really bashing the store
right now and really coming after the
town coordinator [ __ ] you is what I say
to you because I some of these girls
that are complaining women whatever the
[ __ ] are haven't even been out there
though you [ __ ] you haven't been to an
open mic in 10 years you haven't been
booked on a regular show in years and
now you want to jump in the [ __ ]
middle of the line you think you can
follow Diaz no [ __ ] you can't that's
crazy you think you can follow row again
you can't they can't follow Jessica
Michelle singleton and she's [ __ ]
terrific you don't need me out so I'm
saying the people you haven't heard of
and the people you heard of are all
slinging because you can't go up at
those hours and not bring it if you're
not bringing it you will be boxed out
that's just how it is
what spilled I wish you I wish you could
see my
welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
Squarespace ready to start your new
business make it stand out think it
dream it destiny is calling it says you
need a new website make it happen with
Squarespace the future is coming make it
brighter with Squarespace
keep dreaming but making a reality
brother with a website from Squarespace
this is what I'm gonna do today head to
squarespace.com for a free trial when
you're ready to launch when you're ready
write all your goals down and get this
business tip-top Magoo and turn your
cool ideas into a website go to at
squarespace.com get yourself a free
trial and when you're ready to go
use offer code Church CH you are CH to
save 10% off your first purchase of
website or domain this is your chance
that squarespace.com enter code Church
the podcast is also brought to you by as
I like to call the goods on it eyelid
supplements are always there for you you
know why I'm still here tick tock Magoo
two planes breathing on people's [ __ ]
neck
why because a shroom tech immune you
take two they take that time to take to
the more [ __ ] people I see the more I
take I'm up to about ten shrimp eggs
immunes a day and you don't see me
[ __ ] call for this Sneasel around I
got kids shroom tech immune shroom tech
sport you want to last longer this is
how it this is how it's done and for
that [ __ ] protein that's needed the
[ __ ] hemp for its protein the cocoa
will put a pep in your step but don't
take it from me go to adam.com right now
and press in charge BAM and get 10% off
your first order if you go without for
brain you want to get your head together
get a little alpha brain listen to me
you don't like it you get a hundred
percent money-back guarantee and we
don't want the part first
February 1st 2nd and 3rd bison Super
Bowl week nice and cold I'll be in South
Philly for Super Bowls and the Eagles
will beat the Patriots alongside I'll
show you somebody in the business
hi liters already might even need a
mushroom I'll also be at the talking
stick in Arizona this Saturday with
Andrew Dice Clay good for you look up
when you I gotta ask you a question when
you got into comedy mm-hmm
I could tell that the woman fact I've
never even came into you but I don't
even think I don't even think about it
it's like it
it ruins you like it should I do not get
like what's like like I got here all
Joey you're gonna be a great Latino
comic what if I didn't want to be able
to you know write what if I just wanted
to be a [ __ ] comic you know Lee and I
go to this fourth wall comedy open mic
right down the oh you're kidding
five hours for five minutes oh that's
great is that haha no no down on the
corn on Burbank guy Joe cool guy you
know and you're going there you sign up
for five minutes
you're why'd you have to sit and watch
your butt oh yeah 45 minutes show choose
support which is [ __ ] great so people
just don't do that time and leave and
like I was telling Lidia that alley
every time I go up the guy goes I don't
know why this guy comes here like when
he brings me up he goes I don't know
what comes here that's a lame thing come
up the best and people don't know that
when you're doing open like those open
mics like remember when uh when one of
those fights they took rock you back to
a shitty gym oh yeah like a rocky got
real Richie rock III yeah we want you to
see the eyes these were your eyes look
like when we walked in as much angry
blackness yeah yeah ugly you know like
white [ __ ] people who are angry and
[ __ ] who are broken
yeah hit a shoelace or wasn't you know
they have happening on a shoelace
protein they got a shoelace for dinner
and that is splitted because that either
for lunch they got so hot yeah and
that's why I go there I go that but I
told Lee that I went there for three
weeks in a row with Lee and I came up
with a conclusion that going through
those open mics reminded me
that what I was thinking about them is
happening now yeah that's so [ __ ] up
they look like all those rooms and that
wasn't an open mic and I go home at 9:00
do coke and cry like some day yeah wait
a beli room like I would cry it my one
that's so bad just and I didn't want to
be a star I didn't want to be on TV
I just wanted to recipe to be funny yes
that's what everybody misses then that's
why I don't like I like that open mic
it's a great open mic but I also see
that people always are chasing the wrong
thing yeah like they're chasing I can't
wait to be at the Comedy Store
I can't wait to be on TV oh yeah let's
just go for being [ __ ] quality it's a
real city you know what a [ __ ] great
idea being funny you know what that
means you can be funny in Iowa before
the in Idaho you could be funny and
[ __ ] North Dakota yeah look at you
like but we're in California why don't
you try to be funny there then come back
yeah and then come back learn the but
nuts and bolts but by going there that's
what it gave me that like I see women
there mm and I really want a hug
yeah like the chick from Alaska
Reno mm-hmm the drug addict chick there
won't have it and there's this big tall
white chick that's cooler than [ __ ]
she's such a good good kagome she
doesn't know how funny she really is
even though she's [ __ ] hilarious
they're hilarious young comics yeah and
Felipe sat here one day and said then
when he first did his first open mic
that [ __ ] and all the people who were in
the room doing open mics also Alonzo
Bodden right and you go to those places
and you're like three out of 20 people
that's sitting here I'm gonna be [ __ ]
Dean kicks Dane Cook's you know they're
gonna be Joe Rogan's they're gonna be
Paul Mooney they don't know it yet yeah
it's tough to sell it up you know yeah
cuz it's a dream but the thing is you're
right they chase like I gotta do this
rolls and if I don't get into the Comedy
Store I'll never I'll never be
successful and I'm like you're looking
at it completely wrong because you're
when you're not even working at your
craft you're just hanging out here you
should be on stage
two three times a night even if it's if
you don't have the $5 to go up I mean
there's rooms everyone if you want to
get there are rooms everywhere when I
lived in Boulder guys there was an open
mic on Tuesdays and there was nothing
like on Mondays you don't know me poetry
readings I snuck oh yeah I chase them
hey you owe me karaoke wasn't I stuck
there ha ha and got chained up to do you
know any rooms I went and just proposed
people Tommy and then we'll go up then
do 10 minutes and I just bomb and then
go call me in a week that meant
don't ever [ __ ] even come on this
block don't yeah because you have to
create your own momentum when you're
doing stand-up but everybody always
waits for somebody else to create their
own momentum I have to give you
something to work with
yeah that's something to work with
yeah that's the only way I can help you
is by give me you know people contacting
me I got six minutes that's great you
know Silva's done quite a long range
euros a they got six minutes when you
want from me you gotta get 40 minutes
back at wint and off yeah and then we
could work on the road together need to
do feature work and it's not that easy
people think in Kamiya it's a little
saving well if I could do a guess that
would jog the yes Tonight Show be on
stage what are you talking about
so this is a hard time chewing and
[ __ ] walking and bubble gum at the
same time it and you wanna [ __ ] latch
onto the wagon there's no wagon here
there's no wagon you gotta get your own
wagon and you got nobody understands
that yeah and I love like it's like when
I don't know who it was I think by the
third woman I have put on the podcast I
started getting hate mail on Gmail
you're kidding oh yeah oh you mean cuz
they're complaining or yeah
they shouldn't have woman and I was like
guys these [ __ ] women have stories
you shouldn't mire them more than the
guys because women go through ten times
the [ __ ] guys go oh sure because
they all get called into a back office
come on in let me help you oh my god
really you're willing to do this
playing you suck that dick they're all
Harvey Weinstein's all those comedy
Booker's when you come in they're fresh
teddy
oh no experience they try to bust that
hymen as fast as they can and they
realize you're not gonna give it up and
then they put you to the bottom bun
bottom of the list and then the girls
like this is [ __ ] just cuz I didn't
second stick [ __ ] you know what he
wanted you know what he wanted what he
wanted do never give them an inch you
know they talk about all these actresses
that are something [ __ ] female comics
get tormented mister I know I don't
meant that a few months yeah why I just
wanted to talk to you Ellenor cuz you
you've been doing comedy ever since I
moved to LA seven years ago oh yeah you
started as a as a waitress at the store
mm-hmm and I started working with Joey
your zoo because I was a fan of comedy
but I never wanted to do comedy and like
what made you make the jump from like
working at the store to trying comedy
well at the store I would [ __ ] around in
the kitchen you know let's hold court
talk a lot of trash that's what we used
to and all everybody would say you
should be doing stand-up but here's the
thing that happens in Iowa to to a lot
of people so I feel like I don't want to
do stand-up I don't I'm here for
something different I want to be a real
actress I don't want to be no and so I
never want I had no interest in doing
stand-up comedy do you remember the
night me um it's you're standing in the
back and I was telling her a story about
calling the cops on a bird the first
time I ever called cops in my life and
you said tell them it to you about you
tell them it see what you did and I
started to tell mitzi a story and I was
and she looked at me and she went at it
get to the punchline I almost [ __ ] my
pants I wasn't a comic but I knew the
fear of Mitzi shore and when you tell a
[ __ ] story
get to the point [ __ ] right like so and
that's who I was under the tutelage of
kind of but I didn't realize it so yeah
uh when I Freddy
when Freddy Soto passed away I think
that was the break he like everything
became clearer like what are you doing
why aren't you following a dream because
he really would break my balls all the
time to do stand-up and I'm like why and
go on the road and be miserable like you
you know I would just break his balls
back I never thought of it but then when
I started doing it it was one like a
one-woman
to me I wasn't thinking like oh I'm
doing stand-up because I watched the
greatest stand-ups in the world for 12
years some of the worst - by the way
some of the most horrendous stand-ups
you've ever seen in your life come
through the Comedy Store as well not
just the best so you see every side of
it when you're not wanting to be in it
you know II mean like as a waitress such
when after Freddie passed I was like I
left my second ex-fiance that was dice
sorry dice and started doing this
one-woman show and then dice came to see
and he was like you're doing stand-up
stupid and he took me on the road with
him and I was it I got raped in if you
will it's uh is that the wrong word he
is just a rake or a crepe well also
because three months in he took me on
the road and the nerve of me to be
opening for dice
three months under my belt but I took
the gig because I was like oh he
convinced me that this could work and in
California they were so nice to me and
we had that show on vh1 at the time they
were so cool to me they were like
Eleanor but we love you from the show
but then when we got to New York that
[ __ ] got cancelled and nobody knew me
from the show and they were there and we
were mad at uh not Madison Square Garden
for a theater in the round in Long
Island have you ever done that one and
so it's in the round and I go out and as
soon as I say I'm from Philly you know
New York they're like [ __ ] you [ __ ] the
Phillies [ __ ] the Eagles and I'm like
[ __ ] you fact like I remember being so
mad like I'll [ __ ] fight everybody in
here and my sister Karen drove up from
South Philly to watch me and they're
booing and they're [ __ ] chanting all
kinds of crazy [ __ ] and I'm so new like
I don't know how to handle it I think I
got a few like good lines in like
somebody says that where's dice and I
was like he's up my ass you want to
tickle his feet I think that was only
and then I remember catching eyes with
my sister and she like put her hands up
like what do you want to do I'll fight
this whole [ __ ] room I'll fight Long
Island right now I'm not afraid because
she's just like me but she's 10 years
older but she's like a nutty and so
I he he didn't hire me on the road for
like a year because he said go get good
if you really want to do this and that's
what I did because getting booed off the
stage really kicked my ass but I mean
when you get boot from the front the
side in the back that's that's tough
would you feel afterward oh it was oh I
remember
on stage being sweating so bad that my
bra I had a cute little half Ron under
my shirt it slid down so it was like
tumors on my stomach I was like [ __ ] I
gotta get out of here I did a full six
minutes to like the nerve of me to stay
out there but I remember feeling like
[ __ ] this I'm [ __ ] better than that I
can do this I for some reason it didn't
make me want to get out of it and when I
called my family to kind of vent they
were like yes so what they boo everybody
everybody gets booed in the beginning
like they were just like who cares keep
doing it and the next night I went on at
the State Theater in Jersey and got
booed again so you're right it didn't
hurt as much as the first night but it
was there and then that's when dice made
the decision like alright I'll take you
out again but I need you to go get
better so it was about a year I just did
every I was working at a furniture store
and I did every open mic everywhere I
think I did every Shai did the M bar I
did Marty's you could pay for it it's
five dollars or something like that for
five minutes on our side
I think it's sunset fuller right we're
all right so Marty's I would be there
all the time Comedy Store on Sunday
nights Adam Barnhart used to let me run
the sound or the lights and then he
would put me up so that was an extra
spot and then I would get on downstairs
like it was just [ __ ] hustling and
then I got better I got I wasn't great
in the beginning I had beginner's luck
when he saw me and had a good set you
know and then I got ripped to shreds
right there in New York that was pretty
tough but every time I go back to Long
Island I have the [ __ ] best sets
I'll never bomb there again see I would
know that I would know it
well I booked the Nashville one year I
didn't even [ __ ] go to Tennessee not
even if the plane broke down I was
thinking I'd parachute in to somewhere
else really anywhere I bombed early on I
just avoided
like that that's never gonna happen that
was that was my way of [ __ ] you know
somebody videotaped it and they put it
on it was myspace at the time I was so
[ __ ] pissed and then dice found it
and he put it on his MySpace page and
he's gonna see I told you it was hard to
open for me I'm like you [ __ ]
why would you he goes on I just wanted
people to say it's hard to open for me I
go yeah I know it is but I they put two
veteran comics on before me it took a
15-minute intermission and then I went
out yeah it was the hardest thing I've
ever done in my [ __ ] life yes but why
would you put it back out there you go
and then I don't know who took it down
but somehow it went down when dice came
to you and said to you that you wanted
you to take a year off that bother you
at all yeah yeah cuz I was like oh [ __ ]
I failed I didn't do I didn't do it
right and then he would come see me
still though he saw that I was working
he was still coming to the store he
would still you know show up and in the
belly room and see that I was working on
Sunday sad every night any night they
would let me on I would go on and he
only saw me at the Comedy Store but he'd
call me and be like hey can you come
over we're having dinner whatever
holiday it was and I'd be like I can't
I'm doing these four shows tonight and
he's like what so he still breaks my
balls about oh she can't do it tonight
she has 50 shows so but I still do it
like that you can ask him he he gets
pissed
we gotta listen here's the deal you
don't comment that's the only way you
get good at stage time comics come up to
you and they they fart
amazing pants or whatever happened it
was serious
I got me on these are my [ __ ] don't get
wet you know these [ __ ] zombies have
a blocker in their back like it has like
a tampon they're filthy we're in an ass
pack like Ari yeah it's very it's a
really rough conversation for me and I
get aggravated hmm so I mind my business
because there's nothing
that bothers me when somebody comes to
me and says this is what my plans are
I'd like for you to give me your advice
and then you give them their advice and
they take your advice and they shove it
up their [ __ ] like their answer and
then you don't say nothing you look at
them and go watch them hang themselves
and they hang themselves on their own
yeah I know you know we've been through
look I'm not a [ __ ] uh a [ __ ] last
comic winner that came on board with
eight minutes now you know it's funny
when people today somebody sent me a
tweet Joey we saw your own basketball
that's 1997 okay it's 2017 that's yeah
what do you [ __ ] years ago you think
about that you know while enjoying you
wasted your time for a long time I'm
Milan I might have but I do know one
thing I know the journey of the comic
yeah waste your time you built it I know
the journey of economics I see where you
are it takes me two [ __ ] minutes to
decipher where you are what materials
coming out of your mouth the pauses
you're taking if you're soundin what you
have on how you are towards the club and
I can make an assessment right there
I could tell you right there what time
you need how much time you need to
disappear how many you know every 90
days to reevaluate your goals I need you
doing 25 sets a month yeah well what do
you mean I need for you to do 25 sets a
month won't let my girlfriend's parents
that that want that I don't need comedy
because at this time
Aryan it's that crucial when you're an
open Michael you're not gonna working on
Fridays and Saturdays those are the
nights you bartend yeah and you get a
job on the table Sunday through Thursday
is your open mike Ville hmm that's when
you have to be out every [ __ ] night
if this is what you really want
yeah if you're just dilly dallying me or
whatever and it's so weird how every
process is different for everybody
I had a friend here moved here kept
asking me I said this is what you need
to do to avoid everything yeah first off
we'll get head shots and I'm gonna come
agent that lets them know your book a
book yeah as dumb as a commercial as
soon as you book a commercial they know
you could hit you be a [ __ ] star so
now they they they treat you differently
now even the club owners they're sitting
at 11 o'clock at night they look at me
my openers on a [ __ ] tide commercial
right BAM
that means at any moment leaked a book a
TV show yeah if he booked the commercial
he booked a TV show now that demands
respect something I never thought of
because Bill Hicks said if he did
commercials you're a sellout you follow
me so I decided to sell out early
because it was my way on the board the
first thing you want to do is score the
wingman Patriots score first yesterday
hey even if it's three they put up three
because they know how important that
three is even if it's two even if they
get you in a [ __ ] what's that call
safety safety they don't give a [ __ ]
Bill Belichick knows he has to get on
the board first going to Marty's and
going on haha going all these places
ain't put you on the board first
no it's making you become a better comic
but I'm trying to get you on the board
yeah and then once you got on the board
you can play a little bit that gives you
more leniency that get because if you
book that again you got to book another
one mmm now you're on the board twice
even though you're still doing stupid
spots yeah around town that don't matter
yeah now that qualifies you for a
manager or an agent that people that
were representing you commercially now
they're gonna represent you theatrically
because you put money in their pocket
after the second booking you put money
in their pocket you asking about
theatrical they're gonna tell you to
take an acting class and you're gonna
say yes I am with the money I got from
the [ __ ] commercial I'm gonna take
these for like an acting class for eight
weeks
doesn't have to be [ __ ] yeah Ahmad
Rashad acting school man it could be joy
bananas acting school is they teach you
how to fog up a class how to read a
scene another cold read the scene that's
and then make sure your stand-up skills
those five minutes you're gonna mix that
with your auditioning skills and
somewhere in between that
that's called an audition when Mitzi
shore audition you what you give it
three minutes a man three minutes you
look at me and go Joey
I can't even get
my first word in three minutes you
better figure it out you better figure
it the [ __ ] out in three minutes you
just have to show them that you're you
you you and this wasn't for a movie role
that goes away this is for your [ __ ]
life
yeah this is for your [ __ ] life hmm
when you go up in front of the greatest
comedy wolven book of all [ __ ] time
Mitzi sure you know your legs are like
even your dick shrinks up and there's no
cold water anywhere to be found in that
[ __ ] original room nowhere it's just
a weird process so when I look at the
young topic I could tell you what you
need to do first of all I hate that they
develop here hey yeah hey hey that they
develop here because you put so many
different outside forces into yet that
don't need to be there forget about all
that just get funny yeah just get from
one mom I'm sending a taping for
America's Funniest Videos you shot
yourself in the leg right then then
don't worry about another that [ __ ] just
work on your set get ten minutes of the
funny and get out to that [ __ ]
Mexican rooms they're hand to hand
combat oh yeah we went the one last week
the best embraer hit the handcar 988
people on a Tuesday late and that's the
process and then look at that and go
okay this is what I'm doing for the next
six years
I'll Drive an hour 45 min wherever to do
though the great resource yeah to do a
free set and people go free I know good
little for free then sit on your living
room yeah sometimes they'll give you 20
bucks for gas in the beginning if you
tell yourself I'm not gonna be a
millionaire your mind Lissa's that's
right your mind listen all I'm doing
right now is punching the clock every
day yeah and in 20 years I'm gonna check
from these people yeah that's all I'm
doing that I'm gonna simplify this when
you go to a job you punch the clock then
you get in your car at night you turn
the ignition on you're watching the
clock when you go that open mic and if
you ever notice you ever have the nights
where you over had plans yes I come to
stay on Tuesday and watch this episode
of TV with my girl
those are the nights when you go out and
something big happens yeah it's the
nights when you're like you have plans
with some jerk-off or something to do
something yes is it going to change your
life really all my relationships take
off you go
that movie's gonna have to wait and they
look at you like but I got flowers
that's great they're gonna die what are
those mothers yes I'll be back before
they died don't worry I'll bring enough
flowers oh my god
when you start losing friends and
relationships over calmly and people
looking like you're really gonna tell me
think you're gonna risk my cousin's
wedding did you want to do a shot when
Oklahoma you're like yeah yeah that's it
they don't understand that they don't
understand the 10 years from now when
they see you on TV they'll call you yeah
thank you
you really wanted that dream oh my god
I'm so happy [ __ ] you and your [ __ ]
family you're their family come on down
later visit me what I'm doing my [ __ ]
yeah I mean it's tough it is hard it's
but I love it and I I don't book
commercial so I don't know why I've been
in a million auditions for commercials I
just it's a look it's so funny it's a
look at that I'm called back I've gotten
real close I've gotten on hold but it's
never been on is that we're close yeah
but it's funny it's like I don't know
why commercial every time I see what I'm
like yeah I guess I don't really fit in
or I have to be really odd-looking or
really hot probably I don't know how am
I looking
and I even book on what if I go out for
commercials stannie
our book woman I believe it easily book
a pizza a tow truck
Freddie lived off of Freddie had one for
a spanish-speaking bill what is it a
Pacific Bell out here and he would be
dancing in the middle of the street
singing in Spanish yes but it paid his
bills for [ __ ] years now it doesn't
do that year sometimes you catch a good
one man yeah I caught a good one ten
years ago that
there and paid me three times anything
but they don't have even better because
they'll ship they show respect the [ __ ]
they shoot you really don't wanna [ __ ]
see ya half the [ __ ] I shot em believe
that's a commercial Freddie was thrilled
that it only played in Mexico Muhammed I
shot a commercial one time in Denver
he shot something for seven days for
Sears mm-hmm and I shot something for
somebody else and none of the
commercials got Benny but we were so
happy he was just happy to be out there
for a [ __ ] week yeah getting per diem
living in a [ __ ] hotel away from his
wife and [ __ ]
no it's it's a very weird journey comedy
and it's hard enough but I got the
utmost respect for women because you
guys go to places that I'm going to
during the week I know what goes on I
don't know what those I know poyo loco
and Silverlight yeah that guy could be a
[ __ ] pedophile and torment you and
don't go on stage till I've had the
whole uh you know what were you gonna do
for me for stage time all the time I've
gotten at a million times and I've been
like what do you mean I'm gonna make
your audience laugh and then they'll be
like you know you just play kind of dumb
if you will for a second and then he'll
go this is just one particular person
but he was like what if you don't make
him laugh and I still didn't get
anything out of it and like it just
persistent like that and I'm like well
what would you like why don't you say
what you want and then they get real
nervous I'm like you gotta say what you
want after what you want
I don't play [ __ ] get him figures
here it's just figured just [ __ ] tell
me what it is and I'll tell you if I'll
do it and then he really shut down and
ever since then has never disrespected
or done anything what about the people
that come to you nice to you hoping that
someday you bring dice by there oh
that's every foul horrible it's in a
field if you do that to me you're
[ __ ] mad I lived through it for 10
years with Joe Rogan I still listen I
still live through that you still live
through it people who send you're nice
things and be nice to you and then
there's always a by the way you're
waiting for the by the way you're
waiting for it and then they drop you
with the [ __ ] paint mint can you give
this to Joe or key yeah Joe mouth do
my niece was living with me for a little
bit and I told her that that had just
happened to me that this person was
trying to book me booked me tell me how
great I am this that and the other thing
you know they love me they want me to
headline you think dice would do my
birthday party and I'm like [ __ ] you so
I got pissed I and I just we wrote him
off like that was it and now he's like a
big producer a comedy producer only
shows but he's still nobody technically
and so he so forget about him I'm at the
Comedy Store with my niece two days
later and this guy comes up he's like
man I want to put you on my show and
he's got another pretty big show it was
on Comedy Central and he was like I want
to put you on my show man
I'm like oh that's awesome and my niece
is like great this is cool witnessing it
yeah she was all excited and she's like
oh you know this guy has a show on
Comedy Central I know it she's like I'd
love to have you on our show you think
you'd be great you kill it you think
dice would do it with you that night and
I'm like dude no that I've never heard
and my niece's face really happens all
the time it never hurt my feelings it's
more like now I know what type of person
yeah well they're all [ __ ] you every
[ __ ] out there is [ __ ]
technically I'm sorry not when it comes
to this let me give some shoutouts for
starters I want to give a big shout out
to Bobby Sharon and Krystal from getting
could hook tup last night they got
engaged in [ __ ] Austin they were
there with us all weekend I want to
thank Danny Brown for coming to the
shows and run white we had a great time
in Austin I want to thank my girl big
tool for you uncle tank-top Swift of
Rivia big boat gonzo Larry bird flu
alejandro Donna's Dennis Reynolds and
Todd McMartin I also want to give a big
big big [ __ ] shout out to Charlie
Gouveia he gave me a beautiful DVD
things to do in Denver
and I also want to thank Jennifer Joseph
for sending one of her classic books to
my daughter she's
we don't my daughter enjoyed the [ __ ]
out of it so thank you very much
unless you guys know it I will be at the
Charlotte calmly zone
Thursday Friday Saturday ticket to go
fast don't come crying to me like you
did an awesome that you didn't know
because tickets a gun Doug so I'm just
advising you won't have a great time
Thursday night and then next month I met
the Comedy Works in Denver I have no
[ __ ] idea what we comes you went you
know now because the tickets are gonna
go [ __ ] fascinating they come crying
to me again award that no crying don't
[ __ ] cry don't sleep on it oh they
have a limited buy the tickets I can't
travel that much less is it come on come
to Jersey to a Point Pleasant is it ok
if I plug my nose i'm song convinience
is hard to sell point peasant is the
like on the Jersey Shore
the problem with uncle Vince don't
there's a lot of people on Friday but
Saturday all those people Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Friday so I'll
contact some of my dogs down there Gary
Gary basketball brothers sometimes I put
out at the Pennzoil Vinnie's pier right
yeah as long as you're specific I'm
we're not playing oh [ __ ] it's Illinois
it's just uh I see what you do listen
man I see what people don't you know
before 2007 I used to get these calls
every day from comics you know like when
I got the Longest Yard shipping me and
ask me like what do I need to do and
there were all people that wanted to
talk to talk but they wanted somebody
else to do the walking for them yeah you
know fan-like there was so many people
that you could tell in this town they
want you to do the work for me of course
and that's that's great I appreciate
that you know but nobody could do the
work for you that you need to get in
that certain place because even if
somebody put you a little people get
lucky people get lucky they can put on a
show at the five-year mark a stand
that's a great scratch great but you
still got to do that time yeah do the
work you still got a key catch up on
that stand-up work because I love
that lives guys go on the road I love it
they think that doing them problem what
we do is the same thing of that [ __ ]
laugh guys I laugh at home cuz what I do
on stage took 20 years to get there what
you see a lot of these guys doing on
stage we think Dave Chappelle just
walked off the [ __ ] that's right both
from Africa you know no he's been doing
it for [ __ ] 25 years what makes you
think that you're gonna stroll up here
after four years and do what we do you
then I got a couple of good sets I'm not
done that there's a lot of funny people
out there what I'm saying is to really
have that stage that stage those stage
chops and whatnot that's [ __ ]
sensational so I see that you're out
there people like you can't quickly beam
down ray Theo von I see as younger my
favorite there every [ __ ] night and
then I get these people that want a
ho-hum it cuz they were working on their
[ __ ] Conan set and Conan doesn't even
know what the [ __ ] they are so this is
what this episode was about from that
mentality even for Eleanor Eleanor I've
seen ripping up you know farmer I bring
you with me if you're alive we go to
Philly whatever because I know Helen
Helen always killed him that week would
be a thing you know they told [ __ ]
know that everybody knows that and it's
not because you've got in the back of
the Comedy Store or because you jiggle
some of these balls is because of what
happened when Angela you know least does
comic Andrew truly took me out and me
yeah I mean he made me work for people
are always dick but I worked my ass for
it just sucking his dick to his work
that was when you a date it was a lot of
work but let me tell you something I get
likely when I see Lee on stage my jingle
because it doesn't surprise me he
watches every special yeah he's been
around this 35 years and he finally you
feel it realizes voice he's like a
[ __ ] little Woody Allen up on stage
it's frustrating
yeah baby's got a hunger to death first
the kid anyway I'll see you guys
Wednesday I can't wait to see you
perform ready to rock don't forget Helen
off February a January 31st February 1st
2nd and 3rd Point Pleasant New Jersey
uncle Vinnie
uncle Vinnie's and I'll be at Charlotte
North Carolina this week at the [ __ ]
comedy zone ready to [ __ ] rock I love
you [ __ ] have a great day thank
you for listening
stay black what up oh yeah stay black
and don't forget about me all right oh I
forgot the most important thing let me
talk to you [ __ ] about some
number one hot it when you're looking
for supplements you looking to make
restitutions this year whatever people
make resolutions you want to start a new
vitamin you want to get your vitamin you
better get your body in shape going on
it listen they got kettlebells they got
the bats they got [ __ ] vests they got
everything but on top of that they got
supplements supplements to help you
achieve your goals supplements from
shroom to export to shroom tech immune
they got an after workout protein they
got a before what I mean they just got
it and as far as the protein shakes the
acai vanilla and the cocoa whatever the
[ __ ] you name it the hump m4s protein
they're second to none gonna Hana calm
right now press in church and get 10%
off your beautiful first offer delivered
right to your house number two you want
to turn a cool idea into a new website
you want to showcase your work you want
to blog or publish content do you want
to sell products that you man and
services promote your physical online
business announce an upcoming event
listen all that could be done with
Squarespace they do beautiful templates
created by world-class designers they
got a powerful ecommerce cut
functionality I'll let you sell anything
online and the ability to customize the
look and feel settings and product with
more than just a few clicks
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box a new way to buy domains
and choose from over 200 extensions
analytics that help you grow in real
time
and a belt a built-in search engine for
top optimization and 24/7 award-winning
customer support
that's what Squarespace office you're
right so do me a favor right now go
check out twelve acecomm for a free
trial and when you're ready to launch
you use the offer code Church si-hu rch
to save 10% off your first purchase of a
website or a domain that squarespace.com
at the cold church listen you want to
start a business this is your first you
want to start a website this is how to
do it you want to showcase your work
this is how to do it
go to Squarespace calm enter code church
and get 10% off your first purchase of
the website or a domain I want to thank
Squarespace
I want to thank on it and I want to
thank Eleanor Kerrigan for coming on the
show today and breaking down all this
woman's march [ __ ] stop March and do
stand-up [ __ ] I love you guys
we'll talk on Wednesday stay black see
you then
[Music]